this is a production of Cornell
University
my name is Jacob Johnston I'm with the
project yard map at the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology a citizen science program
aimed at creating habitat in your yard
show you the yard map application online
and the website and how we use that yard
maps essentially allows scientists to
better understand how landscape use and
gardening choices affected birds and
wildlife populations in a residential or
urban settings in terms of coexistence
were realizing also that a greater
diversity of birds and greater diversity
of plants and wildlife around a
neighborhood or around a group of people
improves their well-being this is true
in almost any demographic in almost any
society and so what yard map seeks to do
is collaborate with groups of people to
join people together and to create a
community of yard mappers a community of
people making connections or connecting
points connectivity is a very big
concept in ecology that connects large
expanses of wild areas through small
expenses of while there is like yards
one yard that's yard mapped and is being
managed for wildlife is great two yards
is even better because that provides
stepping stones from say a National
Forest to you know like Saranac or
something then you have you have these
stepping stones of habitat and when you
have stepping stones connected you have
corridors so you have corridors and
stepping stones and all of this you know
when a community works together to
provide all the necessity necessary or
an essential parts of a habitat across
the landscape that's when we can all
make a really big difference so what I
want to do is show you some of yard map
yeah some of the best practices that we
suggest and some of the tools that we
have for for planning it yourself and
this is our website is our new page and
new home page
it sort of demonstrates what I was just
referring to that the actions of you and
your community and create a larger more
efficient and
habitat so an animator yard map a yard
man takes a google image of your house
you outline it
and then you fill in the habitats and
then you place objects like trees and
bushes and bird feeders on that habitat
and it creates a yard map like this I
will show you that in a second
you
here's our active participants
adding habitat so
objects to their yards and then when you
do when you add say you know a native
flower bed or native flower garden to
your yard you you document that and you
it tells the scientists here at yard map
so let's see up here on this top bar we
have a lot of resources
you explore resource will show you will
take you if you put in your zip code
here
this will show you your plant hardiness
zone and your ecoregion and give you the
list of bird reports local experts
States native plants this is a really
nice link here that gives you
suggestions
available plants that you can buy and
then here's places where you can buy
them and here's places where you can get
together with community can begin
community events that are around you and
that's all based on your zip code and
plant hardiness zone so that's one of
the things that yard map allows or you
know provides a resource for and then we
have the top learn we have them learn
articles which are constantly updated
articles referring to best practices
basically native lawns replacing are
non-native plants with native plants
they're escaping you know to mean
anything you can think of rain barrels
cats and so there's just a lot to learn
from that section there
but what are what we the citizen science
part of it here is the mapping
here's our this is an example here of a
map that's been created
and we can take a look at
other maps have been recently created
they're right now there is a project
going on up in Canada where they are
encouraging elementary schools to map
their schools so here's the map way each
of these sections is an outline for the
tool
and then each of these trees replaced
so again
and show you a little bit of mapping
so first two phones
first you would find your house say this
is my house here
line tool
you pick whether using a home or it's a
school or a community garden you can map
farms parks preserves and if you have
something else that's unique like we
have a couple of yard mappers that map
their balcony you know they live in a
giant apartment building but they have a
wonderful about garden on their balcony
so they use this other two just map the
balcony so I'm going to pick a home and
I'm going to
assume that I know the boundaries of
this house this property and so that's
what it takes there
it saves it
then you
a tool
the long
I'm going to be really rough about this
but you can i'll show you some intricate
examples that are really well done and
some forest here
all the dots are movable you
expand the range or you can move the
whole piece around like this
you
you
there's also
buildings
so this gives this gives us area
and type of habitat but it doesn't give
us everything but you want it what
happens next once these things are
mapped you go into the
you go into the characteristics page
information I'm going to call my house
my home the characteristics does it have
a garage
or is it a home this is a home so then
it like we want to know about the roof
does it have a green roof or going to
have a white roof because white rooks
help with I'll be to effect with warming
of the climate around you and things
like that you can put in some comments
and you can upload photos
that's for almost every object every
object has and every habitat is going to
have these characteristics that you can
include information for like the lawn do
you use an electric lawnmower or a gas
powered lawn mower or push reel lawn
mower that sort of thing everything is
going to have a different collection of
characteristics once you get the entire
area filled I'm not going to fill it
right now but once this area is filled
that's when you go back through you find
you go to the object tool and you can
start adding trees
and say this tree
not sure what happened there for you
you
you
army just give me one second here
save for me
oh there's the tree okay
when you open the tree
you can type in the type of what you
want to call it say it's your notes nice
i have a big swing in the tree or
something and then this is an
interesting part here you can put in
this and say it's a red maple i'm going
to put an acer
start to type species lists will come up
this is where the citizen science data
comes in really handy
because then we have species and
abundance on the in each of these
properties
so that's one of the one of the things
that you can do with your egg map
you
you
you
and then also we are starting to really
integrate the yard map with all of the
other citizen scientists programs so if
I open this site again
I can try keep getting an error message
I can't list all the birds that i have
seen on this site and this uses the e
bird
this uses the e bird citizen science
program
and so what you do here is you add data
to the Ebert
program through the yard map program and
then that ties them together and
eventually what we'd like to be able to
do is connect nest watch and Peter watch
with these so that when you put a bird
feeder let's see
the bird feeder there's a lot of objects
down here on the bottom if you look
those planters cactuses everything from
wildflowers to bat houses and bee nests
there's a birdhouse I'll put a birdhouse
and the wall on here
so that it won't be long before you can
connect your nest watch data with bird
houses that you put on your land or on
your yard man so like if you notice here
yard map is in beta we are constantly
growing and expanding but right now it
is is very usable and very very fun to
use we have a lot of people that enjoy
it and we're really glad that folks like
you are interested in learning about it
so you can take it to your communities
and put it to use and get get feedback
for us here at the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology and provide much better
habitat more
efficient
have his hat for
I'm sorry it's going to be losing this
okay well if anybody would like to see
anything
let me know this is a
two quick demonstration of this but it
definitely takes a little bit of a
learning curve to learn to use first you
know here's a handsome exploring to use
the website here but
once you get the hang of it it's fast
and a lot of fun so we do have a lot of
uh
extension ten members using this with
their communities to create groups and
things like that and so what we've been
focusing on recently is let me see if I
can if you all a sneak peek
this is behind the scenes this is not a
live site here but what we are working
on now is this group's function and this
is what we'd like people that work with
the communities people that work with
other if you'd like community gardeners
or planners to collaborate together and
to work together in a group so this is
the new function that we're starting
here
and these groups you can find a group to
join you can start your own group you
can create let's see you can see if I
can pull one up here yeah and then you
can compare your group to other groups
and you can compare yourselves within a
group so if you're in a group thats a
native lon see you know native lon group
and you're all trying to get the least
amount of lawn on your yard and the most
amount of native plants or something
then you know you can you can compare
each other's efforts through this group
function here and that will probably be
live in a few weeks so it's something to
look forward to their
through the learn and the Explorer tabs
but eventually after the group
functionality that we're working on now
the next part the next tool that we're
going to add to the yard map network is
called a planning tool and that will be
a second map that you sort of lay over
the map that you have so the first you
will assess what you have and then after
that you can plan what you want and yard
map will make the connections for you so
if you want you know to put in the
native garden the yard map and they pop
up and say here's native plants for your
area that will work to attract the birds
that you listed you want to track you
know what I mean something like that
right now it's sort of using the
resources to explore on your own but
very soon it will be one that is a
planning tool that gives you the
resources and suggestions what you would
do is go to the explore tab and put in
your zip code here
and
one of the best resources that i found
that we've found per plant suggestions
is this your stage name native plants it
takes you to the Lady Bird Johnson
Wildflower Center
and it will give you a suggestion of of
native plants and you can filter that
suggestion too if you want trees or if
you want bushes if you want them to
flower in June or if you want them to be
you know dry dry site type flowers you
know what I mean there's a number of
ways you can filter the selection to get
kind of what you have in your yard if
you have a dry site it gets lots of Sun
with acidic soils and you want something
that gets about four you can enter all
that into that so there's 16,000 almost
17,000 sites across the country we do
have some sites in Mexico lots of sites
in Canada we've got a couple and like
Costa Rica couple in Europe we're really
trying to work together with the Google
Earth or the google maps to make that
more accurate right now the the software
isn't as accurate as it needs to be you
know lining up a Google Earth picture
with our with our mapping tools doesn't
quite work very well so people have some
difficulties outside of the country
Canada and Mexico seem to be fine but
any further outside of that and it's has
to do with projections with map
projections and things like that that
we're working on but the engagement is
always going up this number was 200,000
acres Maps just a few weeks ago so we've
almost had 40,000 acres mapped in a
couple of weeks so people are always
coming back to it there's no commitment
to come back to your math although we do
try to encourage people to always be
adding and changing and updating what
what they've done to their yards you
know if any changes you make to your
yard we want to know about it you know
and then know any any differences that
may have come about from that so there's
no like I say there's no commitment but
as often as you want or as few as you
want we try to keep people coming back
at least once a year with any changes
that are made if the tree fell over or
you know they change their gardening
techniques or something like that yard
mapped org
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu